what is the arrow of time
it's the simple fact that the past is
different from the future right if you
were an astronaut in your spacesuit far
up in orbit far away from everything
else there would be no arrow of space
all the directions you can point in
would be equally good you wouldn't even
notice you wouldn't be able to say i was
facing up or facing down but
not obviously that's not true for time
everyone agrees on which direction of
time is yesterday and which direction is
tomorrow
for example we can remember things that
happened yesterday none of us can
remember things that happen tomorrow
even though things will happen so
there's a million ways in which one
direction of time moving toward the past
looks different to us than the other
direction moving to the future and that
directedness from past to future is the
arrow of time
this is a great example of a problem
that only exists because you learn a
little bit you didn't think that it was
a problem you don't you don't see
aristotle or descartes worrying about
the arrow of time right well what
happens is we developed some notion of
the fundamental laws of physics starting
with galileo and newton and working up
through maxwell and einstein and others
there's a feature of newton's laws for
example which is that they don't have an
arrow of time they treat
directionality toward the future and
directionality toward the past exactly
the same
one way of saying it is if you if you
make a movie
of an egg breaking and being scrambled
and you play it backwards it's obvious
that you're playing it backwards right
you notice it that's the arrow of time
you can notice when someone reverses it
but when you make a movie of a pendulum
swinging back and forth
very simple system where we made a movie
of the earth going around the sun
another very simple system if you played
those backward you wouldn't be able to
tell
that they were reversed and that's
because when you have a small number of
pieces fundamental physics without
dissipation and friction and noise and
all that stuff there isn't any error of
time so the the puzzle that we need to
explain is how to reconcile the absence
of an arrow at the microscopic
fundamental level with the obvious
presence of the arrow in our everyday
lives
but with that pendulum in the earth you
say there wasn't an arrow there was an
arrow it just it just wasn't obvious it
was just harder to see because of the
visual properties of the system wasn't
it no if you if you look at the
equations uh look at the equations for
the earth going around the sun they're
reversible right if you take the earth
put it in the same position but reverse
its velocity it will exactly retrace the
path that it took so the fundamental
laws of physics have this property that
for every
way that you can evolve forward in time
there is an exactly corresponding way
that you can
evolve backward in time
the macroscopic world is irreversible
you can take the egg and you can
scramble it but you can't unscramble the
egg very easily or to put it this way if
you come across a cool glass of water
it might have been the 10 minutes ago it
was a cool glass of water or it might
have been a warm glass of water with an
ice cube in it you can't tell the
difference from the present state of the
system whereas newton's laws say that if
you know the present state of the system
you can always uniquely tell us where it
came from but with your glass of ice
water or your scrambled egg why is it
not the case that it is reversible just
our feeble minds couldn't possibly come
up with the complex equations well it is
at some level so if when you looked at
the glass of water instead of seeing
water you saw with your eyeballs the
position and velocity of every water
molecule
and your brain was good enough to do the
calculation then you could reverse it
and that is the secret to reconciling
the microscopic reversibility to the
macroscopic irreversibility namely that
in the macroscopic world we don't see
everything we only see some
coarse-grained features of reality when
we have the air in this room we don't
see the position of velocity of every
air molecule and it turns out that in
that coarse grain description of reality
the past is very very different from the
future and the way that we characterize
this is by entropy
of course entropy is the way the
physicists talk about the disorderliness
the messiness the chaoticness of the
macroscopic universe and there's a law
of thermodynamics the second law of
thermodynamics very famous says that
entropy increases toward the future
that's easy to understand actually
getting messier is a very natural thing
the hard thing to understand is that
entropy was lower in the past
that's the same statement as entropy
increasing toward the future but there's
no easy dynamical principle of physics
that would explain why the entropy was
ever low
in particular in the real world it was
low 13.7 billion years ago near the big
bang our our observable universe started
in a state of exquisite order and then
ever since it's been expanding and
cooling and disorderliness has come into
being so really it becomes a cosmology
question we understand the equations
behind the arrow of time what we don't
understand is why it was ever put into
the universe at the big bang
does time flow just in one direction
like a river then or are you saying
it is going both ways well time flowing
has always been a somewhat dicey kind of
simile or metaphor because flowing means
changing with time and time doesn't
change with time we when we speak about
time we don't use very precise language
very often but i think you know an
accurate way of saying the same question
is does time truly have a directionality
or at the fundamental level are both
directions of time on an equal footing i
would say that at the fundamental level
both directions of time are equal that
when we uh observe the arrow of time in
our real world it's just like the arrow
of space here on earth remember when we
did the analogy with the astronaut we
had to go up into orbit far away from
the earth here on the surface there's a
difference between up and down i should
say down and up right
why is there that difference well
because we are in the vicinity of a very
influential object the earth that's what
gives space its arrow locally what i'm
saying is that the reason why there's an
arrow of time is precisely analogous
there's an arrow of time in our
environment because we are in the
vicinity of a very influential event the
big bang there's two kinds of questions
that uh arise here one is a good kind of
question one is a not so good kind of
question the not so good kind of
question is there are many many people
out there who just deny the fact that
the origin of the arrow of time is the
fact that our early universe had a low
entropy uh there were debates that went
on from the 19th century from the you
know 1870s with boltzmann and maxwell
and gibbs and low schmidt and zermelo
and others trying to figure out how to
reconcile microscopic reversibility with
macroscopic irreversibility and they
sort of solved the problem halfway they
said if you have a low entropy condition
long ago then entropy increases and
everything follows what they didn't do
is explain to us why we had a low
entropy boundary condition very long ago
modern cosmology says you know we can
blame it on the big bang
it doesn't solve the problem right it
just puts it off to the big bang but we
don't mention the big bang when we teach
people thermodynamics or statistical
mechanics because that's all about
predicting the future it's not about
retrodicting the past so many people
including people who know a lot of
physics
don't get that you need to put a
boundary condition at the big bang to
understand the arrow of time those
people are just incorrect
the other thing of course is well if you
do want to explain why the early
universe had a low entropy what's the
right explanation does inflationary
cosmology already explain it does
stephen hawking's wave function of the
universe already explain it you need a
multiverse to explain it should you just
accept it as a brute fact and not look
for explanations these are very good
questions these are all viable
alternatives on the table and it's part
and parcel of what we discuss in modern
cosmology you live on earth as a human
you have you had to be here at three
o'clock you've got to be on your plane
tomorrow time rules your life as a human
when you think about time as much as you
do on this higher plane does it affect
your everyday life do you just do all
these times that somehow seem irrelevant
or
other two very separate parts of your
personality well i think that the way
that we human beings very correctly
perceive the world is a multi-leveled
way
and especially if you're a working
physicist you better think this way you
know you don't need to use the standard
model of particle physics to scramble
your egg that would make life very very
difficult indeed so we have different
kinds of vocabularies we have this
fundamental vocabulary of particle
physics and quantum mechanics and
relativity and then this higher level
vocabulary of thermodynamics and fluids
and objects and solids and an even
higher level vocabulary of human beings
and their wants and desires and
aspirations and thoughts and rational
reasons and so forth so they all fit
together there are connections between
the different levels and it's all one
consistent story i believe we haven't
figured out all the details of that
consistent story but i get just as
anxious when i'm running late as anyone
who doesn't know anything whatsoever
about the arrow of time
the higgs boson is a tiny little
vibration
in a field called the higgs field just